Patrick Starr on the way up to our ichi
live a food looking at like a queen
we're posing or last looks before we get
up here for the interview we got to do
some some lip gloss a hair a turban
check all the things alright we're doing
last looks and then we're gonna walk up
here you know you cannot you can't rush
beauty
we're live people look at this
all right there's your microphone follow
me I'm gonna have you stand right here
we are live already oh my god one the
only Patrick Starr is joining us hello
oh is the pressure on for Drakon to pull
a Luke I mean I think all of my my
viewers are so used to seeing me just
the face cuz I do beauty so I think it's
really nice to show up and show out with
a beautiful gown today and you showed
what's the inspiration behind this the
story Bob my gosh I partnered up with
finem to walk in their runway show for
the board this way Foundation yes gaga
so we're here to just show out this is
um by a beautiful alumni outfit I'm
Dustin so very cool I love it all right
well how is your drag on going so far is
insanity here like I have glitter all
over my body there's so many looks and
it's so the energy in here is so amazing
people are lipstick a death dropping
twirling and it's so fun it is a feast
for the eyes that ears everything that
all the senses are on high alert you're
amazing
is there anybody that you're eked out to
see today oh my gosh just all the looks
like what all the kids are doing and
what they're learning and inspired from
from the show I think it's really
important to see the youth supported and
just walk around and authentically be
themselves and that's what I'm most
excited to see all these kids and their
talent shine through definitely it's
like it's so cool to see all the
families and the young here celebrating
that experience
yeah this we have a little crowd
gathered to watch Janet does this ever
get old or like weird seeing how I just
never know I just never know it's always
fun and unexpected every day's any day
all right we have a little game here
they were falling-block me
hey you can pull a block okay there are
some questions on those bloggers a
question on the blasts and then you have
to answer it there you go yeah okay all
right what is welcome it says give up
the Internet or bathing for a month
oh this is what I do I would I would
give a bathing for bud oh my god yes you
do
I breathe on the Internet yes okay all
right another one yeah I think you're
going for you're trying to find I'm just
one sound the blood this is spike oh
that one's hard I was trying to go from
closer to the top
[Music]
there okay yeah I think you can get that
one
[Music]
there we go love or money love okay
everybody's at Longfellow yes always
love yeah alright do one more one more
just we're getting to know the real
Patrick Starr now Oh another blank line
Oh another blank one I think oh my gosh
okay I'm in a pole one for you
okay okay the question is the ghosts
that are get dumped over a phone call or
over a text he goes to there's no good
there's nothing good here over a phone
call yeah that was me personal closure
all the way and I need to hear it from
the person yeah hear your voice tell me
you don't love yeah yeah all right this
is a wild experience just have you had
to compare this to VidCon which is a
crazier experience that on its way more
colorful way more loud there's way more
fashion and there's amazing businesses
that I'm here to support but yeah no one
is looking for a cloud they're just
looking to be accepted and be recognized
so I think that's really important here
and I'm so thankful that drag Con is
here to give them that it's like it's so
beautiful to see everybody coming
together to celebrate one thing if you
guys have not been to drag car you guys
need to come on the next one support be
an ally to support these kids support
these businesses because it is such a
sight for the eyes and and I am in love
with it and I'm so honored to be here
and I can't have you here and not ask
about the beauty community has been
through a little some prank lately right
James toddy Jeffrey yeah what is your
take on that whole situation I'm glad
it's over
I thought we can get back to what we're
meant to be doing and the only drama
that pastor has on the eyes
okay glitter lashes and that's what I'm
here I'm here to support people just to
give kids inspiration and I think that's
that's what it is it's over it's done
with and we're just here to inspire kids
to live their authentic self yeah did
you were you able to speak to any of
those involved James or Tati and I
attended try the generous launch party
for her Kylie skin spoke to James he is
alive he as well he is healthy and
that's what I think it's most important
that he is here on this earth to live
his truth and sharing his integration
with witness millions of fans and you
know as for all of them you know we are
here and we have a responsibility we've
been blessed with our platforms to do
what we were meant to do which is make
up those sort of things because you guys
do share your lives with the world but
what you want to share right people have
questions beyond that how do you
navigate that kind of tricky territory
what you just gotta surround yourself
with the right people amazing friends
that love and support you and I think to
navigate and just keep your eye on the
prize what is the angle what are you
meant to do and I checked myself every
month every week like am i doing what I
meant to do am I happy and my fulfills
and yeah safe to say you are happy and
fulfilled yes what is next for Patrick
Starr what are you conquering next
conquering axes panning through this
drought contracted by every single jewel
earring as possible I like I'm so
excited
yeah Jews are like one thing you really
want to leave this weekend with just
just happiness and positivity and and
the best of luck and blessings to
RuPaul's Drag card yeah it's amazing we
won't leave it on that positive note
thank you for dropping buzzed wrong okay
let's start that let's get on the judges
how do I look like this I think I look
cute
I think you look good I think you're
ready for the job all right thank you so
much Patrick Starr remember easy live is
live all weekend long from Dragon Con so
don't go anywhere
stick with the street